j'espère que vous avez pu apprécier tous
ces conseils qu'on a pu vous distillez
durant cette ces quelques numéros on
vous a appris pas mal de choses à
négocier des formats de route à vous
préparer à vous échauffer je vais vous
rappeler quelques principes sur le choix
des chaussures par exemple la chaussure
vous savez c'est vraiment pas un poste
qui est à négliger c'est c'est vraiment
essentiel privilégier le confort demandé
c'est pas la peine de mettre des prix
exorbitants mais demandez à voir une
chaussure confortable ne les prenez pas
trop petit
parce que si vous retrouvez dans des
descentes prononcé par exemple wauquiez
vont buter dans la chaussure et là vous
risquez de vous blesser
c'est l'occasion de vous dire d'ailleurs
que l'hygiène des pieds et notamment une
coupe régulière des ongles des pieds
pour la course à pied c'est vital
ensuite l'habillement pensez à vous
habiller en fonction de la météo
n'allez pas courir quand il fait
beaucoup trop chaud vous n'allez pas
coureur quand il fait beaucoup trop
froid pensez surtout à vous hydrater
si vous commencez la course à pied est
bien une fois deux fois maximum séparés
par une ou deux journées bien sûr de
récupération jamais plus de 40 minutes
quand on commence et déjà une fois par
semaine c'est pas mal à un rythme
l'an plutôt si vous avez la moindre
douleur tout de suite consulté un
médecin douleurs articulaires
musculaires ou bien sûr cardio
respiratoire ou signe de malaise ou des
choses comme ça ensuite faut vraiment
tout de suite allé consulter
et puis s'il ya longtemps que ces
passeports aussi bouillage m
vous n'avez jamais fait de sport il faut
aller consulter à partie avant de
commencer une activité sportive
ça c'est c'est absolument nécessaire et
puis n'oubliez pas une chose courir et
ben ça sert à rien pour maigrir si vous
avez juste envie de maigrir regardez
plutôt du côté de votre bol alimentaire
est ce que vous mettez dans votre
assiette
parce que si vous comptez courir des
centaines de kilomètres tout ça pour
maigrir élevage ou d'une entrée de jeu
ça vous servir à rien parce que courir
ça fait pas maigrir ça fait juste se
sentir bien dans sa tête et dans son
corps voilà merci en tout cas de nous
avoir suivis c'était un bonheur de
courir pour vous de vous donner ses
conseils à plus tard